欢迎收看最佛心幽默的财经节目
理财达人秀
我是李兆华
好终于揭晓了
怎么样呢
9月升息一马
这个应该叫做预期中
那现在看来委员们的投票
年底前应该会再升一马
似乎也没有太离谱
昨天晚上美股费半
还等不及开奖
已经先涨了
说实话这段时间大家太闷了
而今天的台股盘中
一度也是气势如虹
上涨超过1000点
但是可能涨着涨着
大家会觉得
毕竟还是有一些问题
没有完全解决
所以今天的台股
留了一个长长的上影线
贵买甚至中场是翻黑的
似乎涨一半
锅盖拿起来一半
那剩下一半我们该怎么看呢
还有哪些难关要度过
因为毕竟不止美国升息
现在欧洲亚洲升息风都在吹起来
有没有可能变成一个升息环境
而AI的成长能否抵抗
这就很重要哦
所以我们必须回归到产业面
今天的来宾要好好的跟您聊
善用工具懂得产业
如果明年的成长性比今年还要高
那就非常值得期待
可以抵御高的利率环境
先来欢迎今天的三位来宾
第一位是我们的报价天王
心腹哥
好天王驾到要来聊
到底联准会这个决策会议
讲了些什么呢
到年底前
可能还会有一次的升息机会
市场到底要担心
还是不要担心
但心腹哥说有一个事情
是铁打的事实
其中选举要来了
选举后尤其第四季
涨势特别凌厉
这个历史不容易改变
而且做梦行情也随即要展开
台股基本面也很好
今天帮您点名
华邦店出手咯
买下银飞铃的No Flash厂
到底记忆拼图的下一步
怎么要来观看
CPU依旧是盘中的强势股
美股的CPU也大涨
他认为看上游是最稳的
等一下来分享
好第二位是我们的黄金右下角
选股教练韦泰
韦泰每次来都要帮我们救个火
这个礼拜天天都有火
不是大力光就是建策跟围影
今天轮到谁
CCL被打下去
連冒殺到跌停板翻不上來原因也是CPU說普及後不需要用到高規格的CCL到底事情是如何会不会是错杀等一下围态好好跟您聊
当然纵观盘面
其实回到产业的话
2奈米是我们台积电
现在最在行的订单满手啦
所以最便宜的黄金右下角
就在封测跟设备
等一下来跟您聊了
好第三位呢
是我们的ETF教父
存股教父古瑜
好古瑜来到现场
要跟大家讲一个事情
这个升息风不止在美国
可能亚洲欧洲都会有
但是如果今天美元走强的话
对于我们电子股的外销
无疑又是一个强心针
他还是非常有信心
在这样的底气下
观众问了一个很犀利的问题
为什么同样一个经理人
手上有主动ETF跟主动基金
却是基金的绩效比较好
等一下谷云独家解惑
现在要进场
是不是选基金
当然有一个好的平台
是一个制胜关键
好 首先有请幸福哥
好 幸福哥
台股 美股都在这边等
像前两天都窒息量了
就是等升息的消息
但今天上影线大概有500点
涨一半而已
你认为其中选举之后
应该会再去涨
再来华邦店买了英飞玲的厂
怎么看
CPU你觉得上游很有戏
来 我们来看一下
那当然联准会这一次升息
算是市场之前就有预测到
因为在前几天
这个升级的几率就已经将近有9成
那投票的结果是12票全数通过
那目标利率调高一码来到3.75%到4%
不过他们也针对今年一些通膨的数据
包括像是这个PCE核心PCE
也有做了一个调升
不过明年整体的通膨会稍微下来一点
变这个2.3%会降下来
那他们认为大概通膨要到2029年
才会看到2%的联准会的一个目标值
我们知道其实这两年
或者说这两三年来
AI带动全球的经济
是有一波蛮大的一个成长
特别是科技业
所以从GDP
你可以发现
这是9月的预估值
红色的
是比6月还要来得高
然后失业率也是下降的
这个都是好事
但是从通膨数据PCE来看的话
其实它也是在增加
就代表说
其实市场有一点点两方在拉锯
就是说虽然通膨高
所以我们要升息
但是警戚很好
這也是不爭了一個事實
所以就看哪一方在這個裡面他的一個角色會扮演比較重這也是左右聯準會的一個決議那當然因為9月開始升一馬之後大家比較關心今年還不會再升
照目前來看的話
最新的一個數據
大概有機會呢
12月會再升一馬
那9月這一次已經結束了嘛
10月還會再開始會
然後11月沒有
12月會 所以還有兩次
那兩次裡面呢
年底現在預估了
還有機會再升一馬
當然這不是絕對的
只是目前的預估
那降息的話
明年可能機率比較低啦
那如果通膨再升高
當然有機會再升息
那中位數目前顯示
大概維持利率不變
所以這個是
目前聯準會的一個態度
那至於說呢
這個會影響到什麼
為什麼大家一直在講說
好像通膨很高
或者說這個只要升息
哇 這個股市就會崩盤
那我認為其實要分兩個角度來講
就是說當年度
到底景氣是好還是不好
如果景氣好
升息可能兩方
就會有一點在拉扯
但是如果像2022年
那一年也是升息
不過企業獲利大幅度衰退
那一定是空投市場
那我們來看一個表
這邊有外資機構去統計
黃色這個是標普500指數
未來一年的EPS預估
你可以很明顯的發現
它的這個獲利的成長
是明顯大於
標普500指數的成長
就代表其實基本面是好的
除了剛剛我們講的這個升息之外
其實9月還有一個歷史因素
我們可以統計大家看
比較黑的偏深色
这个是1960到2026
你可以发现是跌的
是跌的
然后2006到2026
就是近20年也是跌的
那是12个月里面
9月其实通常表现最差
不过大家也不要担心
9月过完之后
10月11月
特别是11月
是每年里面表现最好的
所以我们预估
搭配美国的其中选举
其实第四季
我个人认为是
台股或美股
是有机会再往上走
特别是台股的部分
有机会再来挑战
这个历史新高
至於說美國的期中選舉也蠻妙的
他之前都會先回黨
因為也是不確定性因素
不過選完之後
他們有去統計
一樣從1962年到2022年
每四年一次的期中選舉
其實選完之後
一年平均漲幅大概有14%
所以代表說其實
越接近期中選舉之前
如果有出現像
這個禮拜一、禮拜二那種擊殺
那是不是反而你是要逆向去思考
是不是有機會先去進場
慢慢做布局
那大盤的部分呢今天有攻上去這個短線的反壓 月線不過比較可惜是因為早盤漲幅有點大再加上今天有一些市場的鬼故事把一些中小型的股
或一些之前熱門的股票
什麼CCLR這些壓下來
所以導致漲幅收斂
不過整體來看
目前還是月季線都還是往上走
我認為其實架構還是比較偏正向
是沒有什麼太大的改變
當然我們觀察這個AI
還有一個重要的數據
我覺得大家也可以參考
就是AI每個GPU
它的租賃價格
租賃價格
就是說不是說每個公司
都像Meta 像微軟 像AWS
他們錢多多
可以自己買設備來蓋資料中心
很多專業型企業
我需要AI
但是我是用租的就好
我不用自己花那麼多點去蓋
那你可以發現它的租賃價格
其實基本上都還是往上
其實代表說
其實市場對AI的需求還蠻強的
那至於說台積電的部分
我認為它今年也會再創新高
也會再創新高
那我們上次有講過
台積電今年大概100塊
明年大概130到150
130到150
所以從這樣來看的話
其實即便你用最保守的130去估
其實現在台積電
今天的收盤價大概在2425
其實本利比
P1本利比也是不到20倍
就代表說其實
我認為20倍以下的台積電
不算貴
那你如果去照實反應這個
20倍的本利比的話
其實它一定會過前面的高點
那只要台積電過高
台股就有機會過高
好 真的是一定對不對
我都敢這樣講了
因為佔四成嘛
台積電比重佔台股四成
所以台股過高
台股應該就過高了
是 這是一個
好 那至於記憶體的部分是這樣
今天有大事
今天也震盪很大
那一個大新聞是
華邦電用300多億收購了
英菲林的No Flash
那其實No Flash算是記憶體裡面
一個算是比較小眾的市場
它需求是一定有的
但是其實它跟低潤或跟Net比
它的占比是比較低
那收購之後呢
它會變成是一個
在產品線擴展的
更完整的一個情況
那No Flash的一個
施占率會高達34%
會穩坐龍頭
所以目前來看的話
華邦電透過這樣的一個策略
去讓它的產品線更完整
我覺得對於
它搭建整個公司的護城河
是有更加強的效果
所以我認為這個收購案
目前看起來
我認為是
當然後面的企業整合
還有怎麼樣把這個
收賓進來的一個企業
做更進一步的融進
這個滑棒店的文化
我覺得這是一個關鍵
那記憶體最近大家可以發現很難解
一下漲一下跌 一下漲一下跌
主要几个原因 第一个我们来看一下
DRAIN 左边这是DRAIN的报价
你可以发现DRAIN的报价普遍
大概还是慢慢往上爬
但是呢 这边有NAD跟DRAIN指数
你可以发现 深色这个NAD指数
最近就没什么动了 是很平的
所以如果大家再看 最近为什么
DRAIN系列像南雅科华邦店相对比较强
那NAD系列的股价就比较弱
原因就是因为DRAIN的报价
目前是稍微比较纯现胶着
變焦灼
那還有一個關鍵就是合約價的部分
合約價的話我們知道今年上半年漲很多
甚至到第二季YOY有五成到六成
可是到第三季就開始會收斂了
大概13%到18%
那到第四季大概會到5%左右
所以就代表說
像上半年大家那種
可能整個記憶體一買
直接後面30% 50%漲一倍
可能下半年會很難複製
會比較變成是高低檔震盪
高低檔震盪 為什麼
因為大家預期你這個未來
如果合約價漲不收斂的話
你那個獲利的暴衝期
就會開始放緩
絕對數字還會增加
但是那個暴衝的一個
成長性會開始變慢
那這時候大家就會去找什麼
找更有機會的
暴衝性更好
所以我認為
最近記憶體的部分
雖然我們看這個營收
很多都什麼
500% 600% 300%的一大堆
不過最近高漲震盪也是很劇烈
那我們是認為說
比較偏Dram的這個區塊
華邦電跟納雅科
會是目前比較好的一個挑選
因為畢竟我們剛剛看它的報價
還在往上走
會是比較具有優勢一點
那至於股價的部分
我們來看一下
華方店當然前幾天
還有跌破月季線
技術面是比較弱的
可是大家可以發現
最近回跌
只要是基本面還不錯
其實跌的時候
基本上量都是縮的
好 息瘦了
那反倒是在攻
像今天攻
雖然有點可惜
月季線這兩個大反壓
沒有一次攻過
不過其實量反的是
稍微有比前兩天大
所以它比較關鍵
就是前面這個
比較密集這兩三個
比較密集的套牢區
能不能夠有效的去做突破
那也順勢的站回月季線之上
我覺得是接下來
這個股價轉強的關鍵
不過相對
南亞科已經接近高點來講
他目前大概還在比較偏半山藥的位置
這是一個
那南亞科是這一波有先過高的
不過過高之後
我記得我們上次有來講
就是你看這個
美光
或者說像海利士等等
他們還沒過高
你南亞科過高之後
其實他不可能一直衝
所以要拉回到這個月季線左右不過因為它其實獲利現在單月大概都有七到八塊那很多現在的產能都被長約鎖定我們就先拿今年的獲利做個預估
其實它明年假設都可以保持這樣的數據的話
大概80到100的EPS沒有什麼太大
所以說它其實下檔會有保物
只要回跌到重要的均線支撐
其實它股價就會彈
但是你一看漲追或看創新號去追
可能它會馬上給你殺回來
所以我覺得記憶體的操作
就我剛剛前面講
因為它那個報價的一個
爆衝期已經過了
你不要想說就像第二季一樣
200買突然漲到500
或者說你現在500買
以後會漲到1,000 2,000
我覺得不會
它會變成在高檔來回震盪
有急殺你買 上去
那有獲利你來回操作
這樣獲利會比你之前
長包的模式會比較好一點
這是記憶體
信夫哥之前有教我們
反而到了重要的均線
下跌的時候
才是一個買的時候對不對
千萬不要用追的
這個有教過我們操作的邏輯
還有華邦店竟然變成
Nightflash的世界龍頭
對望宏會有影響嗎
我認為因為其實
現在記憶體的產能還是蠻缺的
所以其實對於望宏來說的話
我認為影響不是特別大
主要還是因為
Netflix最近的報價稍微比較弱勢一點
所以它的股價
目前的整理的時間
可能會拉得比較長一點
好 是個別的問題
因為很多人也很關心望宏
OK 好
那我覺得比較值得關心的
就是大盤現在還沒創高嘛
對啊
但是領先創高的族群裡面
很多檔其實都跟
CPU矽光子相關
就我剛剛前面講的
現在資金會去找尋
下一個具有爆炸性成長的產業
那目前看起來
CPU似乎是大家認同度比較高的
那你可以發現
這個是CPU它的滲透率
你可以發現這兩年
2025、2026
雖然題材之前吵了很久
可是你會發現其實這個
滲透率連1%都沒有
明年開始變2%
變7% 變20%到30%
所以幾乎是從零開始
所以它這個爆發力就會特別強
所以為什麼資金
很多會跑到這個錫光子相關的
讓它的股價領先大盤創高
原因就在這裡
好 那
CPU的從上中下游來看的話
當然很多最上的廠商
都是國外的廠商
像什麼流民光學這些
AXT
對 那台灣的話
我們先簡單
把它做一個上中下游的區分
那目前比較缺的
其實是在偏上游的
零化銀的累晶
或者說它相關的一些產品那像聯亞全新IET這個就比較偏上游的累晶那還那還有做雷射代工的這些那大家都可以看還有像做組裝的一些光模組的組裝
等等這些大家可以稍微去做一個參考
近期今天的股價表現
還有它前八個月的營收的一個年增率
今天很多也是開高走低啦
對 今天中小型都是這樣子
對 那就我剛剛前面講到
很多的CPU或光通訊相關
其實他們都已經過了前一波的高點
而且他們的好處是
其實5月6月台股大漲之後
其實他們幾乎都在盤跌
他們那前一波是完全沒漲到
也就是說他們之前整理的時間
是比目前很多
在第二季創新高的個股
大概多了兩三個月整理
那剛好呢
最近不管台積電或輝達都有講說
今年整個CPU
已經開始要陸續順利量產
所以你可以發現
股價為什麼會領先過高
一定有它的原因
因為之前本來三四月
大家說可能會延遲
所以股價就
慢慢回跌下來
可是通過這樣子的一個
利空洗禮之後
反倒是大廠出來背書
股價就上來
當然因為最近盤勢
我們認為還是震盪比較大
所以我們常常講
你不要連漲才追
比如說第一根或許要有機會
兩天之後還漲
可是你去追到第三根
他可能就給你洗盤
甚至今天創新高
你盤中去追
他盤中就要漲停
漲停創新高
感覺氣勢如的
對啊 如果你想說
創新高了特董啊
进去做今天洗刷一下
最后只涨了不到5%
这个震荡会非常大
那连压也是啊
它也是过高之后
马上给你拉回
但它回档过了哟
对有回档过了
所以今天呢
因为整个CPU也是有点开高走低
所以它被带下来
所以你看你这边拉一条横线
它就过了之前
两个前面套下去之后
股价有稍微再创高
但是马上马上又拉回来
不过我认为短期之内
应该会在这个重要的均线这边
来回去做一个震荡
那我是认为说
目前整个CPU细光子
在成长动能这么强的情况之下
如果未来台股要创高
这个族群应该相对来说
还是市场关注的焦点
好 肩甫管记忆体或者是CPU
其实幸福哥都选偏上游的
对不对
对 目前看起来上游的状况
是会比较明确一点
而且也可以发现
他们的营收成长动能
确实是比较高一些的
好 这边非常谢谢
包教天王 幸福哥
谢谢
好 幸福哥要提醒我们
虽然今天感觉台股
是留了一个上影线
但是目前是一個好的開始
因為畢竟不確定性因素
市場有先拿掉了
接下來其中選舉以及在所謂的第四季都是漲率非常高的以這樣的傳統來說台股俠帶著強勁的基本面很值得期待所以我們不要太過擔心
今天漲一半的問題
反過來看
記憶體其實滑邦店展現的是企圖星
那如果記憶體今天有回檔的時候
先優先選上游
反而不要追漲
下來接 下來接
這樣做價差會比較順利
那另外CPU的部分也是
明年的滲透率會大幅放高的話
上游零化音相關的
也是您的首選
好 廣告回來
延續的CPU的話題
CPU很好
CPU可能要普及了
為什麼會殺傷到
所謂的銅箔基板呢
中間到底問題在哪裡
今天銅箔三雄的這個鬼故事
能不能順利化解
我們等微態來
好好跟大家做說明喔
我是普世分析師
同時也是兩個孩子的爸爸
很多人常問我
到底該幫小孩存台積電
還是0050
其實我的答案很簡單
其实只要定期定额
以年化报酬率8%估算
互利累积下来
孩子成年18岁都会有第一桶金
而问我最看重的是哪一档股票
在我心中
当然就是我的孩子
孩子的黄金发育期只有一次
所以更应该帮孩子存未来
在孩子转大人的关键期
我的秘密武器就是这个
庄广核糖转大人翠滴金
由台湾第一位女中医师
庄熟岐博士开例
有曾外孫三胞胎成長實證
男女配方不同的
成龍成鳳配方
剛好可以精準補給黃金晴營養
是不是都沒有苦味和腥味
對啊 就跟媽媽煮的雞湯要好喝的
嗯 還要好喝喔
投資 我會挑龍頭股
陪孩子成長
我挑有實證的龍頭品牌
這才是最精準的健康投資
好 科技
真的是一個很奇妙的事情
有時候你升級了
你周遭的東西都要升級
有時候你升級的
反而告訴你周遭的東西
不要用到那麼好了
CPU就造成這樣的現象
有人說了
CPU如果全面普及
CCL不用用到M9這麼好
講歸M4就夠用了
到底這件事情是真是假
因為今天CCL三雄
跌爛了
到底是不是一個錯殺
今天幸好有危態來救火
再來我們知道2奈米
這個沒有問題的
培電下個禮拜就有論壇了
所以你覺得盤面上的黃金右下角
就是設備跟封測
好 我們趕快看一下今天
大家最關注的
為什麼今天CCM
CCL三雄
在加權指數大漲超過千點的時候
竟然有人中跌
甚至還跌停板
我跟你講你現在哪一天來都可以
因為天天都有鬼故事
我們先來跟大家說一下
今天的一個故事
市場傳聞
CCL可能會降歸
然後轉向光通訊CPU
什麼意思呢
它簡單說就是
当这个全面改采CPU光通讯的时候
因为呢
这个以前的这些
所谓的一个通讯的讯号
可能要通过这个所谓的一个主板
然后传递这个讯号
可是以后呢
都是靠这个光纤
来去做这个传输了
不要你啦
对 所以我就不需要
我就不需要这么好的
这个所谓的一个主板
那可能呢
现在的这些所谓的
CCL的一个规格
就会从M8 M9
直接降到M4
那么这样子的情况之下
那么这个大家对于
那接下来CCL
可能会面对降低的这个情况
那它的整个所说营收
或者是毛利率
都可能会呈现下滑
所以就造成今天
CCL的相关的个股
都是呈现了一个
明显下跌的情况
是甚至盘中打到跌停
对不对
不过后来台药台光电视
有稍微拉起来
对好
那么关于今天早上
这个市场传闻呢
这个铜箔基板的业者都表示
升级的趋势是不会改变
升级的方向有可能会改变
什么意思
就是说其实未来主机板的部分
仍然会朝向高层数高耐压
跟供电稳定前进
但是可能大家对这种
所谓的一个载板的需求
OK
那可能会因为呢
这个大家都包进去了之后
CQ把它包进去之后
那么载板的这个需求
会往上做增加
好
那为什么这个只是市场传闻呢
因为今天虽然说CCL是这个下跌的
那如果说按照这个市场传闻的一个说法来看的话
那应该是对CPU是好事啊
可是今天CPU也没涨
也是开高走低
对
那么对这个载板应该是好事啊
可是今天载板双雄也是从早上的平盘之上
杀到平盘之下也没大涨
所以有人没大涨有人是重错
對 所以我覺得今天大家在這個
所謂股票上面的一個交易上比較是屬於沒有這麼理性的操作OK 那我個人認為呢因為這個CPO全面性的採用了這件事情
可能要到2028年之後才會發生
是
所以今天的這個所謂的股價的拉軌
只不過就是短線上
市場上擔憂
這個高單價的這M8跟M9
它的需求可能會見點
那麼有一些個本益比
相對比較高的個股
面臨到了一些短线上面的修正
这是我认为在今天排面上面
这个CCL 三雄所导致的一个股价下跌原因
那么长时间来看
逻辑上好像说得通
但是在实务上我个人认为
基本上既然已经升级上去的这个产品
理论上不会这么轻易的去做一个降规动作
就突然跟你说不用了这样子
大家跟认证半天
那我相信大家更关心的就是说
那今天這個CCL
這個股價跌下來之後
有沒有機會去減便宜
是 如果我們從股價的走勢來看的話
對 聯帽就是從頭鎖到尾
對 今天其實這個聯帽
台藥跟台光電
他們今天雖然說盤中都是這個下跌
但是呢 只有一檔個股是鎖跌停板到收盤的
就是聯帽
但是其他的台藥跟台光電
這兩檔個股基本上在今天
都是有留下下影线的
至于说金区跟富桥
他们今天跌幅就更少了
就更少了
所以其实我觉得市场上面
还是有一些就是认为说
这个所谓市场传闻
大概只是空穴来风
至少在今年或者是明年
这个事情不会发生
所以我觉得在基本面
相对人家强势的情况之下
今天这个市场传闻
出来之后造成的股价下跌
事实上是造成非常多的
这个投资人
进场做低阶的好机会
今天其实是给机会
对不对
很多人一看到跌
就会觉得说
这个族群都完蛋了
其实不是这样看
今天都有报非常大的量
我们现在看一下台光店
我们这个台股三本柱之一
现在只剩下台积电撑着
可以啦
还可以是不是
台达店和台光店比较逊色
可以啦
台光店这波往下去
做一个走跌
今天是剛好回測到這個
就是在這個
這個是半年線
半年線破掉
半年線的位置可是之前它的股價也曾經回測到半年線然後你看喔兩次有很類似的情況第一個回測半年線
第二個爆大量
所以其實每一次回測到半年線
基本上它都有出現
就是去低階買盤的現象發生
那麼目前看起來
在前波段這波的一個下跌
我個人認為就是這個投信
回去在这边去做一些
所谓的持股的一个解码的动作
可能做结账
但是我认为以今天
这么大的成交量来看
明天要去做止跌跟反弹的几率
是相当大的
这个是台光店
那么再来联帽
今天收盘跌新版的
因为它之前的姿态比较高
你说的没有错
我们比较一下台光店联帽
跟等一下看的台药
现在就只有联帽
它的股价还在月线的附近
你说这个台光电都回射到半年线的
联帽你还在撑在这个上面
这个所谓月线的附近
虽然跌的相对比较少
所以可能酝酿出来
或累积它的这个所谓的卖压筹码会比较多
所以导致今天联帽是跌停板
所使到这个收盘
但是今天这个联帽
它仍然是一个出现爆大量的一个情况
虽然锁跌停但却有量
对 还是有量
还是有量的
所以我觉得明天可能因为它今天锁跌停的关系
它明天理论上都还有往下再去做一个
侧低点的动作
但是有没有可能出现开低往上再做走高呢
我觉得这个是明天要去做特别观察的地方
这是连茂
再来第三家就是6274的台药
台药呢
盘中也打到跌停
对
虽然说大家好像看起来盘中的股价都是相对弱势
可是我个人认为台药在这三档个股当中
它在高档去做整理的这个角度
其实相对比较平缓
它没有像刚刚台光店这样
是往下杀的
它是往下
但是台药是属于有点走横盘的
横盘架构
那么目前看起来台药
它现在的一个股价
也是回测到的
就是半年线的一个位置
对 台光跟台药涨
一样都在半年线
都在半年线的位置
但是它这波下跌的这个角度
跟刚刚台光店相比
它的这个角度相对比较平缓
是
那原因是因为呢
我個人觀察到外資其實在後面這一段
是有站在這個買方的
他把投信這邊做這個釋出的籌碼全部都接走了所以在台亞来讲比较像是所谓的一个土阳对坐那通常土阳对坐呢在这种所谓大幅度震荡的隔天
基本上呢
他们都有机会出现
直接跟反弹
所以我觉得明天
大家看到这个台药
或者是台光店
它如果说是出现
开很低的话
搞不好都有机会
去做一个风低的诊接
好 而且今天的话
感觉上是盘中消息走开来了
大家才去看
要不然应该第一时间就砍了
对
这个是CCL三雄的一个部分
是
好
那么有鬼故事但也有好消息
有好故事
也好故事
OK好
联发科它最新的这一个晶片
天玑9600 Pro
目前推出来
而且是搭配什么台积电的先进制程跟封装
它应该是很有机会
能够做到所谓的边缘运算的能力
是
因为我一看到的时候
我直观就说又是为了手机
结果后来维胎就说
这就是边缘AI
大家都要从云到端的
对
所以在这样子的情况之下
它至少在我们所谓的手机晶片
或者未来的手机的一个发展上
目前看起来联发科
仍然是遥遥领先
那么赶快看一下
在这样子先进论坛的之前
有没有哪一些的一个公司
或者产业可以特别去做掌握
好 今天就不一样了
这一块是红东东
虽然也是有点涨势压抑
但他们其实
以前8月的累计营收来说
成长率不算太高
说得好
这就是我现在认为
封测族群
我们会优先去做观察的地方
黄金右下角觉得
真正的黄金在这个地方
因为在过去
AI相关的这些的次族群
不管是散热
不管是CCL
PCB等等的
他们的成长幅度都超级大
都爆喷有什么三位数破百的
那这里面我觉得
其实有一些股价已经修正过的
在右下角的公司可以特别做留意
谁呢
哎呦 难冒记忆体相关的
对 记忆体相关的
那最近记忆体的这个热度又开始做增加
是
所以记忆体相关的风色
我觉得大家是可以特别做留意
OK 尤其是难冒
它社会到AI伺服器所带动的
高阶的记忆体滴润
跟DDR有风色需求大幅度的一个提高
所以目前看起来在整个股价
在这边就进行横盘性的整理
似乎收斂接近尾聲
也在半年線耶
對 而且現在大戶的持股
在最近這兩週有出現往上做
增加
那么最近的股价呢
通常啦
技术指标在低档的
比较会涨
对耶
就突然之间一跟上去
就大家这个基本面都差不多嘛
但是呢
技术指标在低档的比较会涨
所以像南茂
现在的KD指标
已经回测到了
大概在27的位置了
21跟27的位置
所以其实
未来这两天
大家可以特别做留意跟关注
这个是南茂
再来呢
就是这个华东
哇他在所有均线下
怎麼時間跌成這樣了
42塊
同版股
43塊
那為什麼挑華東呢
最主要跟剛剛
馨福哥所提到的華邦店
你們兩個今天是對稱的講法
他講華邦店
CPU講到CCL
然後上游講到下游
我們來看一下
因為華邦店收購英飛林旗下的
No Flash跟FRAN的事業
百分之百的一個股權
那华东又是跟华包店同集团的封测
所以我认为说接下来
它有可能会接收到一些所谓外衣的订单
所以目前的股价呢
它的股价拉轨在这个地方
季度指标也在相对低档
要往上去进行黄金交叉
股价也相对比较便宜
好 可能大家都看什么日光晶圆店
反而今天帮大家看了两档百元以下
未接超低的封测
没错 整理到接近尾声
好 再来就是这个制程
这个先进制成封装设备相关的一个个股
设备就很不一定
有人成长九成
有人成长可能两成不一样的样子
对
那因为他们主要所这个
focus的一个产品不太一样
所以这边一样先帮大家
在这个时间点
帮大家挑一些股价
已经做过修正的一个标的
好
6640的君华
君华
G2C联盟
对
这个就是COVA相关的一个设备
它的精力挑减机
施展率是很高的
而且拉货是非常的强劲
那么在最近可以观察到
股价在这边去做整理
然后投信
投信在这边已经开始出现
开始说布局了
同样的KD指标在这个地方
已经回测到相对低档的位置
所以我觉得短时间之内
也可以特别去做一个留意跟观察
而且看起来可以买得比投信便宜
有這個機會差不多差不多的成本OK再來就是這個烈月196的樊宣他今天没表现他今天没表现对 他今天没表现他现在股价在高档做强势整理
也不太想要下去的样子
对
所以原因就是因为
通常这家公司在第四季
他都有这个工程款要进入
这个任务入账的高峰期
那现在在手订单呢
1347亿
OK
现在看起来量缩缩链到尾巴
KD指标
也隨時有機會要往上去進行交叉
是
好 大家真的不要看那個設備股在很黏很洗的時候不理它
因為第四季尤其是11 12月份的時候
入帳高峰
這個就跟剛剛講到的第四季漲率一樣
都幾乎是一個鐵打的事實
沒錯
好 這邊非常謝謝薇泰
謝謝大家
好 有選股教練真好
每次有急的事情他就來救火了
剛剛講到CCL的呼應
如果真的是這樣
那今天CPO應該噴翻天了
因为要普及了嘛
但不是这样子来看的
我们不需要把两三年后
有可能发生的事情
甚至现在无法证实的事情
留在盘面上吓自己
而今天同波基板的三雄
都有爆大量
险近的杀下来
是有人有意愿做承接的
那至于如果要业绩非常稳妥
而且明年的爆发性比今年强的
刚扫到的封册跟设备
绝对是重重之重
千万不要担心他们的成长性不足
明年就可以看到非常亮丽的成绩
好 广告回来
股仪要上场了
有人问我们说
为什么同一个经理人
他操盘主动是ETF跟主动是基金
基金的绩效却比较好呢
是不是买基金才是对的呢
当然你要搭配一个对的平台
帮你省下相关的费用才是最重要的
好 明天的话日央可能也要升息
那美国已经在升息了
台湾央行呢决定不升息
到底这样的利率环境
会对资金流向造成什么样的影响呢
谷余还是很看好我们的电子股外销
这边来请教谷余了
升息不怕 为什么不怕呢
因为我们没有升
对 没有错
好 很多房貸族啊
股票折押族
其實還有點擔心
我們升息這件事
那我們就可以安心的來賺
強勢美元喔
那大家就問了
主動式的基金
好像比主動式的ETF
績效好
那我要怎麼選啊這個背後其實是有一些條件的那當然我們待會兒花一點時間來幫各位投資朋友做一個說明那首先我們的央行
在剛剛宣布了它最新的開會結果
那這個開會的結果
搭配昨天美國的聯準會宣布的結果
兩相一對照之下
我馬上對台灣的電子股充滿了信心
那我們先來理解一個問題
那通常來講的話呢
一旦聯準會他宣布升息
就代表呢
他的貨幣會變得比較強勁一點
那我們的匯率是跟美元做對照的嘛
那一般來講喔
我們要避免呢
我們的匯率被拉開
最好是要做同步升息的一個動作
所以呢
昨天他宣布升息之後
我們就預期今天
有可能會升息一個半碼
甚至呢達到一碼的一個水準
因為我們已經太久沒有去動這個利率了
怎麼會忍得住呢
人家已經升了
日本也要升了
沒有錯
但是我們這是開出來的結果的話
大出所有人的意料之外
忍住了
繼續動漲
對啊
那這樣子一來的話
人家在強勢
那我們是動漲
就代表我們的匯率會變弱
你要知道
台灣是一個出口導向的地方
尤其是我們的電子科技相關的產品
你的匯率越弱
就代表我的產品越好賣
所以這樣子一來一往之後的話
我又對我們的電子科技產業的話呢
充滿了無比的一個信心
賺美元
而且呢他這一次的宣布來講的話
還有兩個比較特殊的
那除了動漲之外
另外一個的話呢
是你的那個貸款的乘數
第二戶
從六成的話呢
放寬到七成
而且呢還有一個是對建商是大利多喔
什麼東西
就是呢購地貸款的部分啊
原本是說呢
你這筆錢借出來之後
在一定的時間內一定要動工
是
那這條的話呢
也拿掉了
所以你看在这一次
央行的会议来讲的话
对房地产这一块
基本上就是一个大利多的表现
那明天会不会涨
营建资产
我觉得这个可能性
应该是蛮高的
就营建跟资产相关的
目前看起来的话
对这一块原本的管制的话
是出现很明确
松绑的一个现象
那当然对我们来讲的话
更重要的是看
科技相关的类股
就算台灣升息了
我們一定要切記一件事情
一旦我買的個股
它的成長率比升息的幅度還要猛烈的時候那你就不需要太擔心了確實 因為我們今天在等這個答案對 其實就算今天我們申辦碼或一碼好了對於電子股來說
應該也是小菜一碟
對 沒有錯
我們要會賺錢的龍頭
這才是最重要的啊
所以你看我這邊就幫各位整理啦
2026年的EPS的預估
然後更重要的話呢
是2027年的EPS的預估
剛幸福還特別講到
講到明年台積電130到150
你直接估一個142.2
這不是我估的喔
這是法人的資料
平均資料是不是
對...這法人估出來的平均資料
而且我們現在已經快要接近到Q4了
對啊
進到Q4大家就不是看2026 EPS了嗎
就開始轉看2027了
所以我就幫你把這份珍貴的資料
我們整理下來
然後我們就來看
有哪些公司
它在成長性的部分
基本上法人还是一路非常的看好
当然我们在投资啊
事实上困难度还是蛮高的
我真的觉得困难度很高
你看刚刚我们的报价听王讲到全新对不对
我们的价值股达人也讲全新
吓死我了
8月19号古鱼独家来讲零化音是什么
还把化学元素表放在这边
那一天到现在涨了35%
对没有错
我真的好失心
可是我們剛剛在維泰哥的嘴中的話
也看到了一個非常驚人的消息
就是台光電事實上在近期的表現
突然有墜落的現象
可是他的業績很好
對 他的業績很好
剛剛也看了 明年我剛剛看了
從EPS要漲到200多塊
但是為什麼他會掉下來呢
就是因為有傳出一些謠言
我覺得這個還不一定
而且剛剛維泰也說了
那個GPU不一定是兩三年後的事情
你現在就這麼擔心他幹什麼呢
所以你看
當大家很恐慌的時候
結果它的量全部都被人家接走了
所以今天去把它賣低的這些投資朋友的話
你有可能是錯殺了這檔股票
我們以前常常在講一件事情
你如果自己沒有辦法選股
那你就交給專業的幫你處理就好了
那我們以前都說專業的要找誰
專業的話當然除了找我之外
更重要的話是你可以考慮
透過主動式的ETF
因為它背後是有專業的經理人
跟專業的選股團隊
他來幫你做操盤的動作
我們來看一下
同時間已經發行的這些主動式的ETF
〔此段辨識失敗，約 40:00 起〕